hello everyone and welcome to the second
day of the finals of the opera euro
rapid it's weirdly so versus magnus
carlsen and this is the first game of
their match yesterday the match ended in
the draw so if this is settled now in
the rapids there will be no uh no
no blitz tiebreaks and of course no
armageddon and it's a quite a
quite a strange game i don't know what
to make of it maybe you guys can
share some insight but uh uh you know
that being said uh
let's check it out so here wesley opens
with e4 as he did
for the uh for the entire uh match so
far we have c5 by magnus going for the
sicilian defense
knight to f3 knight to c6 and now bishop
to b5 going for the
uh medina rossolimo attack have bishop
we have e6 and now castles by wesley
knight g to e7 so this is all
uh very standard and c3 now preparing to
strike in the center and also making an
escape route for the light square bishop
once the pawns uh start attacking that
bishop so a6 bishop to a4
and b5 with bishop back to c2 uh
like in the rule opens you uh waste uh
some four moves with your bishop but now
now with black spawns being
extended so far you will have a target
and you will challenge them
with a4 later on so bishop to b7
and rook to e1 now just continuing
development
rook the c8 and now the immediate a4 so
i'm going after that
b5 pawn uh we have b4 uh
advancing the pawn and now striking in
the center with the d4
uh we have c capture c captures and now
there is a
i think there are a few games where d5
was played but here knight to g6 by
magnus is a new move
so already as of movie 11 we have a
completely new game
uh wesley continues development knight b
to d2 that knight can now come to c4 or
maybe to f1 followed by knight e3 or g3
we have knight to a5 by magnus opening
up this
c file now the knight can also now come
to c4 maybe if this knight moves you can
push the pawn all the way to b3
uh a lot of possibilities here so g3 by
wesley
bishop to e7 preparing the castle and
here
wesley pushes h4 and this is a very very
interesting opening up your king's
position like this uh the idea being
that
if if magnus decides to castle here then
you already have your bishop nicely
placed here maybe you can
continue advancing this spawn maybe
challenge this night saying that
where is this night even going and i
think
magnus was very very unimpressed with
his position here
and he didn't really take all that much
time he considered what to do here for a
little bit
and then he decided to sacrifice a piece
and he played bishop captures on h4
and uh we usually say that if you grab
two pawn for a sacrificed piece then
that's not really a big deal and
especially if you get the attack with it
that's pretty much uh
you know good in itself but here
uh not so much because wesley accepts
the piece with g
captures on h4 knight captures knight
captures on h4 and
queen capture sonny sorry that's a king
and queen captures on h4 and now
you might think all right there's
definitely compensation here the bishop
slices the board in half i mean the
queen is
very nicely placed here i can i can
castle play f5 maybe open up the file
for my rooks i can maybe bring the rook
into the attack
uh a lot of interesting ideas here uh
but there is uh
uh there is one move that completely
shatters
black's dreams so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this move for
wesley while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
not playing anything weird like knight
to f3 and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's
rook to e3 this rook lift is the way to
go and the rook lifts
are often the way to go uh because the
idea is next we're gonna get to the idea
but i'm just gonna i just wanna show you
how dangerous it is for example if you
play something like knight to f3 you
attack the queen
you you immediately lose to something
like queen to g for check king to h2
and now rook captures on c2 just
removing the defender of this knight so
just to show you how uh how uh there are
a couple of
very nice ideas here in the position
okay maybe it's not lost but it is very
unpleasant not to play this for white
with this king
loose like this uh you know in the
classical game probably
white holds this but in a rapid game
it's very hard to say
but after queen captures on h4 wesley
plays the absolute strongest rook to e3
and now this is the idea we have f5 by
magnus striking in the center now
preparing to open up well the f file as
the king will probably castle
and uh you wanna do something about this
bishop not
being able to control this diagonal so
here rook to g3
by wesley and now wesley's plan becomes
clear now the idea is if the uh
uh df file opens up and you try to grab
this pawn maybe play e3
and uh checkmate the white king wesley's
idea was
rook to g4 that's the idea of the rook
lift so
you rook lift to do another rook lift
and now the thing is uh the e4 pawn is
attacked three times you have to move
the queen and after this happens bishop
captures an e4
uh you completely eliminate this uh this
bishop on b7
doesn't really matter what black does
and the black black's attack is
is gone so here instead after rook to g3
carlson castles now
will try and bring a rook into the game
maybe ideas like rook f6
h6 maybe checkmate are possible but now
knight to f3 wesley doesn't uh
allow even a moment's rest for now for
the black queen we have queen to h5
and now again the immediate knights to
e5 offering a queen trade while also
attacking the d7 pawn
and you can't really abandon the attack
because if you if you do that
uh what are you even doing and then even
bishop to h6 and the
black black is just dead lost here so
instead after knight to e5 we have queen
captures on d1
uh bishop captures on d1 and now d6
chasing away wesley's knight from this
very strong outpost
and now knights to d3 there's no no
point in risking with bishop to h6 and
you know giving back the material so
wesley keeps it all knight to d3
and uh wesley's position is now better
he's up uh in material he has a better
position
and the attack is gone and also he's
better on time he has eight minutes on
the clock whereas magnus has five
minutes on the clock
so here f captures on e4 now knight
captures on b4
uh we have knight to c4 magnus tries now
to activate his pieces
and now a5 uh we have d5 here
uh cementing this knight on c4 but now
what is this dark square bishop even
doing it's
very hard to even imagine this bishop
ever being a part of the game you would
somehow have to maybe shift it
all the way here to do to do whatever
but
it's very unlikely so here bishop to g4
by wesley going after the e6 pawn
rook to f6 defending and now just bishop
to g5 wesley tries to chase away the the
rook
and now the rook has to go back and give
up the e6 pawn but they just that
just runs into check and then the rook
on c8 is gone as well
so here magnus played not that obviously
magnus played rook to g6 and wesley just
played
bishop to h5 now challenging the rook
again and now the rook has nowhere to go
you have to pick up the bishop which he
did
captures and captures and after this
captures on move 28
it was in this position that magnus
carlsen resigned in the game as his
position is just
terrible after only 28 moves
so yeah really really impressive stuff
by wesley
i have no idea what happened here and if
uh
maybe maybe maybe magnus just thought
that having this beautiful bishop on
this diagonal after this uh
all this has been said and done for
example after h4 that his bishop on this
diagonal would be compensation
enough in this position here and it does
look very nice i mean
why not maybe you know if if nothing
happens maybe
you can even start pushing the pawns but
as you've seen wesley played
every move every move by wesley was the
absolute strongest move recommended by
the engine so
uh he he did not flinch even for a
moment and uh it was uh
enough to you know completely shatter
carlson's idea
and take the full point in the first
game so very interesting stuff we'll see
what happens in the rest of the match
but so far
so far if if uh the the three remaining
games
end in a draw then wesley so will once
again be the winner of the finals that
feature
magnus and wesley so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank you mccarthy uh
nano by the bay
uh scott beaker a mystery person in
dominic deja for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the rest of
the tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day